-Our first guest tonight
is an Oscar and Emmy
Award-winning actress
you know from films such as
"Marriage Story"
and "Jurassic Park"
and shows like
"Big Little Lies"
and "Enlightened."
She is also the coauthor
of the new book
"Honey, Baby, Mine:
A Mother and Daughter Talk
Life, Death,
Love and Banana Pudding,"
which is now available
everywhere.
Please welcome back to the show
Laura Dern, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Hi, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-I always genuinely love
talking to you.
And what I love
about this book
is I feel like I'm talking
with you when you read it
because this is a conversation
between you and your mother.
And this is the kind
of conversation, I guess,
that you guys had never
had together before.
What was the sort of catalyst
to approaching
having these conversations
together?
-So my amazing mother,
Diane Ladd,
who is such an extraordinary
actor and been,
you know, the light of my life,
got a health diagnosis.
She unknowingly --
In her neighborhood
were surrounding farms
and they were using pesticides
and spraying
without notification.
And when she discovered
there was this lung disease
from scarring
from the pesticide exposure,
they said "your mom likely
has 3 to 6 months to live"
and there was no medicine
or support,
so they said, so they hoped
that by walking
she might get more strength
and expand her lungs.
And so she really
didn't want to do this.
Let's be clear, she said,
"I hate walking.
I had to walk 10 miles
to school when I was little.
Don't make me walk more."
And at the time
she was on oxygen.
It was very difficult,
and she loves telling stories.
So I said, "I'll tell you what,
we're going to walk each day
a little bit further
and we're going to talk
and I'm going to record it
in my phone,
and your grandchildren
will have it."
And as my mother says,
you know,
when you think
you're going to go,
you tell each other everything.
But the gift of the experience
was we discovered,
as close as we are,
and we're actors who've
worked together on films --
she was also
in "Enlightened" with me
and David Lynch's "Wild at
Heart" and "Rambling Rose" --
we had spoken about so little.
We had skirted from the deepest
and most heartbreaking
of moments in our life,
and I never asked
her things like,
"What's the first movie
you ever saw?
Why did you want
to become an actor?"
And this was the discovery
of an intimacy
we don't share enough
with our closest of loved ones.
-And then the real happy
ending as well is health-wise.
She's okay?
-Also, to quote my mom,
this occurred
at the beginning of 2019,
and she will tell you,
"Four years later,
I've done two movies,
a TV show and wrote a book."
So...
[ Cheers and applause ]
But she does believe
that the walking did in fact
give her more energy and that
the talking and the healing
and us loving each other
was a major healing
and that she didn't
believe doctors.
She was like, "They're
'practicing' medicine, Laura."
[ Laughter ]
So she's like, "I'm going to get
several other opinions."
And she believes
in alternative options
and worked very hard
to be here.
-Well, I'm so happy she's here.
One thing that must
have been very surreal
is, so, you record her
on these walks
and then obviously
you transcribe it into a book
and then -- which is
a great idea, obviously,
because you have
a couple of actors
who have written a book,
you record the audiobook,
so now you're back
in the booth,
basically rerecording a
conversation you've already had.
Were there ever times
where you thought,
"Oh, now that I'm getting
another chance at this story,
I'd love to..."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. I mean,
you had two actresses,
so it felt like doing
a one-act play or something,
but it was so personal.
And in the moment
we were sharing everything.
And the only reason
we ended up doing this
was, as we started
sharing our story,
it was inspiring
friends, my children, people,
all different relationships
to communicate more empathically
and knowing
that you don't necessarily
solve anything or agree,
but you ask the questions
and you hear each other.
But once we were in there and
we heard some of the responses,
there is a story about my mother
taking my son for a haircut
when I was out of town,
and I'm still livid.
And we did the audio recording
and at the end of it I was like,
"You are so wrong.
I can't believe you did that."
And we got in a huge fight.
We needed to take five, guys.
-It must be interesting
because the first time
you're listening,
you're thinking,
"Well, she's only going to be
around for another three months"
and now she's fine.
You're like, "I got a -- I have
a different answer."
[ Laughter ]
-That's what she says.
She was like, "Wait a minute.
Why did I go through
that whole story with her?"
-You know, one of the things --
You guys, your first film
was a film your mother was in,
and Martin Scorsese directed it.
And an interesting thing
is your mom talks
about how she had anxiety
when you told her
that you wanted to share the
same profession that she had.
And it's funny
because I had nothing,
you know,
I shouldn't say nothing.
I had a lot of anxiety
in my career.
I've had so much more joy
than anxiety.
But if my kids said
they wanted to do it,
I would have the same thing.
Weirdly, I would think about the
downside more than the upside.
-Yeah.
-Was that the first time
she had shared with you that she
was worried when you said
you wanted this path?
-I mean,
at the very beginning
she was very reticent.
But I was a kid.
I mean, I did the, you know,
played an extra
in my mom's movie,
"Alice Doesn't Live Here
Anymore" with Scorsese.
And I was a 7-year-old.
But I fell in love with this,
for me, incredible team sport.
It was the first time I had sort
of seen a team sport at work.
150 people come together
to make one thing,
as you all well know,
on this incredible show.
You know, it feels so good
when it works, right?
It doesn't always. But anyway.
[ Laughter ]
But this always works.
-Of course.
-So anyway, just so we're clear.
-We keep thinking we're
going to have a night
where something falls flat.
But yeah, not yet.
-No, no, but it's, you know,
it's so invigorating
and she saw my passion.
But as you said,
she also saw the pitfalls,
especially as a young girl
of entering an industry
where she couldn't always
be protective of me.
So she tried to talk me
out of it, but it didn't work.
-And there's a lovely story
about, as an 11-year-old,
you took steps to further
your own career at a party.
-[ Laughs ]
Yes, it's so ridiculous.
But it is true that I was 11
at my mom's friend,
the actor Bo Hopkins' house.
And I went up to an agent
and I said,
"My mom won't help me
and I want to be an actor.
Will you let me audition
for you?"
[ Laughter ]
-It's the most Hollywood thing
to bring your kid
to a party and be like,
"Now, don't -- If I catch you
talking to agents..."
-Yeah, stay away from the
agents.
-I have a lot more questions.
We will be right back with more
from Laura Dern.